Oh, yes, hello, hi, how's it goin'?
Have you ever been working at an office, and one day wanted to g-
Look up porn?
What?
Hi, how's it goin'?
It's me!
Markiplier!
Welcome to this game!
Where am I going?
Ahuh- AWAY FROM THIS BULLSHIT VIDEO!
HAHA! GOODBYE!
GOD this is the worst intro I've ever done...
Ignore all the insanity that you just saw,
Welcome to NSFW!
*BEEP*
'For your first day with us, please finish all of your training videos-'
Mmhohoh...
Oh, I'll finish all my training videos alright.
'Right click to work or have fun?-'
[sexy music]
[groan]
[louder groan]
Wo-
Agh
Hueey- Hauugh-
♫ Workin' here, doin' work! Lookin' at work! ♫
♫ Don't mind my pants being off! ♫
[sexy music]
Ah! ♫ Doin' work, love to work! My work is- ♫
[loud computer beeping]
AH! OH GOD!
*BEEP*
Alright...
Let's do it!
[sexy music]
*Pervy voice* Yeah...
Heeeeeeeeeey!
Salutations, fellow employee!
I've been doing a proje-
[ Growls ]
*BEEP*
Don't mind the moans! Heh...
So many moans in here!
*BEEP*
Heyeaah!
Huh! YEAH!
HaH-I had a lot of fun!
Fifty-fifty split on work and fun!
Huh hahahahahuh...
[whispers]
What's the point of this?
*BEEP*
Have you ever been working one day and you wanted to look up gratuitous amounts of porn?
Well, now you can simulate it!
Heh Heh Heeh...
Who put all this poop in my pants?
Heh Heh Heh Heuuh
Its a dog, look! He's alive...
He's alive!
That's not the same dog!
I know my own dog and that's him...